our country under any circumstances
always delivers its responsibilities as
allies but despite of this our allies
are talking different to our face but
doing other things at our back and this
is undeniably clear now despite all this
Turkey's attitude is always with peace
and happiness and it will be this way in
the Syria issue in North Africa and
Middle Eastern geography is a project of
redesigning of the region before all the
conflicts in Syria we have showed our
attitude to Syria and we recommended
them to be with democracy and goodwill
especially all the people that were in
that country and weren't even considered
as citizens our Kurdish brothers they
were under pressure our Turkmen brothers
as well were under pressure and we were
insisting for them to be given their
rights I have told Assad many times as a
leader but unfortunately all these
initiations were not considered on the
contrary operation was operation was
chosen over 1 million people lost their
lives during this crisis in Syria this
is how it started in the last eight
years half of the population of Syria 12
million people had to be have to let
their homes and go to other countries
and there's been conflict six million
Syrians who left their country and went
to other countries 4 million of them
came to our country
3.6 million of them are Arabic Turkmen
and as it is but 350,000 of them all of
the 350,000 of them are Kurdish and
these came from kobani predominantly and
four million at the moment came from
Syria pay attention to this almost all
of them who are Arabic unfortunately I I
don't even want to use this expression
but the Arab League it's not suitable
for the arab league arab league i how
many Syrians did you accept our applique
I want to ask you you kicked out Syria
from Arab League and now now you are
insulting Turkey you are trying to take
over Syria this is what we experienced
in this chaos environment all the powers
who took advantage of this chaos and
invented this machine called - in Arab
League today regarding these refugees
have they ever gave a penny for the help
of refugees European Union 3.3 billion
euros they sent to the Red Crescent but
they promised 6 billion euros but even
if this money comes or not we spent 40
40 billion dollars we spent over 40
billion dollars the places that are
there are shower axes these are the
places that all our people in our region
live these this savage group has nothing
to do with Islam and they are the
biggest enemy of Muslims and ashamed for
the Muslims every time there was a step
that could be taken for the benefit of
Muslims - as a factor is always in the
way of course there are as a project
that has been that has been developed as
a project and all these countries who
are responsible for this project
they looked like they are the biggest
enemies of - but we know who played what
role in creating this project - what
started the collapse of - it's us
where did we start this in Al Bob and in
that three thousand - members were
neutralized it was us who did that but
especially fatto
members always made black propaganda
saying as though we are loyal to - this
is like a balloon it's always been
bloated and this organization who can
only harm civilians we fought with them
as I expressed earlier we neutralized
3,000 terrorists - after a freitas
shield operations in Syria we have taken
all we offered to liberate other places
that are occupied by - even our
operation plan was ready but at that
time they couldn't understand but we now
see the reasons very well at that time
instead of a legitimate power as turkey
day
chosen YPG PKK that this was their
choice and they're still together
terrorists when they make a
demonstration in France we were there in
France to share their pain but - killed
50 hundred people many suicide attacks
in our country but we had no one with us
the issue is not a - or PKK it's only a
project in our region it's very clear
every step we take we always see this
very clearly in this situation we had
two options we were even we were either
going to play the role that was written
for us
by the West and the ones that were going
to come right out doorstep we were going
to allow this and we were going to put
our own neck under the guillotine or we
were going to put a fight on